farness a Devan Damian one of the more
complex characters that berserk has to
offer us with the notable trade of being
something of a pyro file who burns all
sorts of things primarily heretics I
suppose but rather annoyingly on at
least one occasion she tried to burn the
subscribe button for the new order view
which luckily being an exclusively
digital existence is immune to literal
fire and instead simply resulted in
fantasy receiving hopefully regular
berserk content uploaded straight into
her YouTube feed hello and welcome to
the new order video source for
everything anime and manga and it is
berserk time again because today I would
like to explore a certain character one
who I feel is overshadowed by I suppose
almost every other primary existence in
this series being fantasy Devan Damian a
character whose journey piques my
interest like no other and to begin I
should say that fauna se is a very
difficult character to me in the best
possible way that is and it's actually
quite incredible to think back on her at
various points in the series because if
you do cast your minds back to say the
conviction arc then this character is
almost entirely unrecognizable to how we
encounter in the Fantasia events and I'm
really not sure that you could say the
same for any other character actually at
least not one who is incorporated into
the main band of protagonists for
example I feel like you could point to
guts at any stage in the berserk journey
and immediately recognize who this man
is and what he stands for
same thing with casts curse same thing
with Chiaki Serpico is Dro and of course
mister puck which isn't to say that
these characters don't develop at all
they most certainly do but fauna say is
a completely different existence
altogether throughout her tenure in
berserk everything we thought we knew
about this character has been
consistently challenged and she has
changed in almost every facet imaginable
be it her basic appearance or her core
beliefs and one of the more stock
examples of this is that obviously fauna
say was introduced as not just a member
but the leader of the holy iron chain
Knights an organization devoted to the
strict protection of religion and
religious figures and it also consisted
of high-ranking nobility and if anything
the whole organization was more or less
a ceremonial existence and of course in
addition to that fantasy was also wildly
selfish at the helm cut to the modern
day and fauna say has abandoned her
defense of that faith and is now doing
the exact opposite by engaging in heresy
through studying magic on she okay with
an informal ragtag band
of common or nobodies of which she is
certainly not the leader vana Singh has
done a complete 180 and that is a very
difficult thing to pull off as a writer
to move one character so satisfactorily
from one end of the spectrum to the
other can often come across as a bit
forced or contrived but fantasies
journey is nothing short of a
masterclass in this realm that sees a
complete awakening of her mentally
emotionally and even sexually in fact I
suppose that last one was very much a
key spark to the character which we'll
get into but vana sighs impressive
character arc is not what I find to be
the most compelling aspect of her what I
really love is that within this single
individual is a full spectrum of human
existence she can be taken to the true
depths of darkness depravity and
unrelenting cruelty but at the same time
through her New York can also portray
the most gentle caring and beautiful
upstanding human being possible and for
some comparisons of the aforementioned
darkness fauna say is an intriguing
childhood led her to as I said in the
intro becoming something of a para file
and thus receiving distinct sexual
pleasure from the act of burning people
heretic specifically but then of course
infauna says case I'm not so sure that
the reason why she was burning people
mattered as much as the act itself in
fact this tendency began as a child when
she was heavily praised by adults simply
for burning people and you know a teeny
tiny filer say had no understanding of
why this act was happening she just
engaged in it which continued well into
adulthood
with the excuse in mind that this was
for the good of the world and I suppose
that's what leads to her redemption in
this particular area due to the primal
allure to sadism and the mask of faith
to implement it final essay does of
course for each point in her life where
she comes to understand the intricacies
of the world around her and most notably
she provides heavy contrast to a
character like father Mosca's who is
infinitely drawn to faith and as a
result will commit any degree of what I
would honestly call evil for the sake of
quelling evil and I'm sure that he would
not see things in quite the same way in
fact he would have likely thought of
them as sacred acts from which he
derived no pleasure whatsoever but also
no guilt from his actions whereas vana
say took a healthy dose of both from her
time with the holy iron chain Knights a
lot of repressed pleasure and an
astonishing amount of guilt showing the
deep down she did possess a more
empathetic nature which from any initial
meeting of the character I would have
thought to be practically impossible I
also find it really interesting to think
about the fact that when we first met
fantasy it seemed like she was a beacon
of confidence she may not have been
experienced enough to be in the position
she was in but she had this innate
belief which was gradually broken down
to the point where the farness say we
see today questions absolutely
everything especially about herself and
in this way she has become a student of
the world rather than the leader of a
doctrine which is another thing that
greatly appeals to me I really love how
me or handles the topic of religion in
general in berserk and fauna say
provides an integral part of that
exploration with that said there is
still an underlying fundamental darkness
at play with fauna say one that was made
most apparent when she was briefly
possessed by a spirit which saw her
attempt to seduce guts and even suggest
that he split her clean in half in the
most arousing way possible of course but
the thing about this event is that this
was not a clear-cut case of possession
this being was far more fauna say than I
think fauna say would ever like to admit
it just exploited her raw desire for
what I suppose will call some fairly
extreme S&M and look as much as we here
at the new world of you do not kink
shame that's a pretty dark place to go
and fauna says life is a constant
struggle of experiences between these
features each competing against one
another and her attempt to reconcile and
discover who she actually is which I
know every time that self-discovery as a
concept is mentioned it sounds like a
reviewer is having a wank made video but
there really is no other way to describe
it and this is also before we start to
examine her noble lineage and the idea
that she was brought up to be a
figurehead rather than an actual human
being as a member of the esteemed
vendôme Ian's house fauna say was
constantly instructed on exactly how to
live her life with any deviation from
that being completely unacceptable and
so as a result of that what we initially
meet in the series is a woman who has
absolutely no sense of self she knows
what she is supposed to be and she feels
supreme shame in response to anything
that breaks through that barrier
revealing her true feelings about any
number of topics and so in many ways
fauna say is still something of a
newborn in this world because after
having her connection to faith and
societal expectations broken she has
only just now begun to explore herself
and I think that's very evident in group
interactions because fauna say is almost
always without fail the most uncertain
member of gutters traveling party even
when it comes to the child members I
mean she okay probably isn't a great
example because she's a magical boss but
easy draw for example the better or
worse makes decisions very quick
and when times get desperate he does
tend to know exactly how to act where as
far as a takes more time to process
events which can generally be seen as a
negative factor in life-threatening
situations but that's just her varnas a
is not perfect
she is heavily inexperienced and almost
never knows what the right course of
action is I think that's why I quite
strongly connect with fan say more so
than most characters in berserk because
in those kind of situations that's
definitely what I would be like and they
honestly feel like that's how most
people would act I am NOT quick thinking
and more often than not I will probably
choose the second-best option in a
situation that requires Swift decision
making so it is nice in a way to be part
of honest A's personal struggle in this
world which isn't just about decision
making but also obviously coming to
terms with quite literally everything
about her heritage desires relationships
belief and so on and so forth it's
actually very akin to the struggle of
guts and Casca
although fantasies is much more of an
emotional and inner struggle and one
that is forever developing right in
front of our eyes but that's not just
confined fantasies character alone
because this also presents itself in her
interactions with others so for example
as you may or may not have picked up on
by now
fauna say has something of an
infatuation with guts which also takes
place on a plane of duality because
originally she was quite disgusted by
him but then broke down and involved a
sense of admiration and attraction and
certainly not just physical attraction
either because fauna say looks up to
guts as the pinnacle of how to live in a
world completely devoid of hope you know
how to keep trudging along when
everything has been taken from you and
how to solidify your place in the world
regardless but what makes this most
interesting as far as says--
relationship with Casca rather than guts
so despite being quite awkward and a bit
of a work in progress when it comes to
battles Varna se did have at least one
undeniable talent right off the bat
which was to form a rapport with Casca
and to be able to calm her which
obviously led her to developing a strong
relationship of Casca one that actually
leads to great conflict within fantasy
herself because on the one hand she
feels a legitimate sense of friendship
with Casca but at the same time there is
an ever-present element of rivalry
because Casca is the object of guts as
unrelenting affections which on paper
sounds like an incredibly cringy love
triangle and usually I hate that sort of
stuff in any series but Miura does it
pretty damn perfectly in berserk I
personally feel genuinely
along with fauna say because I can see
that beautiful bond with Casca but it's
also very easy to feel her immense
frustration with Costco or I guess not
Costco herself but the situation because
guts continuously does everything within
his power to keep her safe and she just
is not capable of responding to that
desire in kind or even adhering to basic
safety protocols more often than not
making situations much worse and
resulting in direct physical pain and
injury inflicted upon guts and you know
come to think of it the whole guts
farness a dynamic is actually kind of
similar to that of Griffith and Casca
one individual admiring another from
afar doing everything she can to help
her infatuation but never having those
feelings returned although hopefully
this parallel ends just a little bit
better for farness either but we should
also not ignore the fact that while
complex the idea that fauna say has been
capable of forming these relationships
at all is incredible evolution from what
she was which was this abstract figure
of the world an outcast in the guise of
a noble figurehead so even coming to
grips with something as simple as
realizing that she does in fact care for
other people
beard guts cast by Serpico whoever is a
pretty big step but we don't even stop
that because fantasy continues to
develop which can be seen in her use of
magic and quite honestly in real world
time she's only been studying the art
for what a couple of months now and
fauna say can already perform feats at
impressed characters who have been
involved in this world their entire
lives so farness a continues to solidify
and sculpt her place in this world on
every level imaginable which is why I am
always most interested to see her
compared to the rest of the group in
certain situations finest a may appear
to be a hinderance or even just plain
useless but this is certainly a
character to keep an eye on and that can
be hard though because she is
overshadowed by everyone else in the
traveling band I suspect guts for these
reasons he's the main protagonist and
gets all the glorious action Casca
because she's the primary love interest
and her recovery is not only the
ultimate goal of guts but really the
readers of berserk as well and then when
it comes to fantasies emerging strength
and magic she will always be
overshadowed by the existence of the
absurdly powerful she okay and with such
prominent characters in mind farness a
can become a bit of an afterthought
which i think is a grand shame because I
really cannot name another character in
this series who has delivered such
consistent substance evolution and who
superbly questions how I directly feel
about them on the
bactrim a berserk fantasy is what I
would consider to be the direct center a
character who has explored the light and
the dark of existence but one that
doesn't necessarily belong in either
count and quite frankly I am captivated
I think the berserk would lose an
incredible amount of substance without
fantasy and I look forward to continuing
to struggle alongside her on this epic
journey what do you guys think please do
let me know down in the comments below
or even join my discord server and if
you came for some more berserk content
then please do go and check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for hopefully regular bizarre
content uploaded straight until YouTube
feed but for now this has been the new
world view and I'll see you next time